welcome to this video playing dbv DB
foul from the US yeah my rating is a
catastrophe 277 I had some terrible
session last arm and then I tried with
warm up games we're also lost like two
or three games now I'm letting my rating
down to the kind of level way I feel
it's tough to lose any more points but
let's see okay I've got a check benoni
here or would be noni a very close
position where it will be all about palm
brakes yeah typical porn break is some 5
+ f4 in this position like very often it
goes with g6 okay so he seems to try to
play be five I can however keep still I
still keep control over that okay Bishop
f6 not not so sure what this is doing
playing this little strengthening moves
maybe I can get before in it's a very
passive position from luck we can mostly
just sit and wait I can think of playing
playing on playing B form
but i can i can still prepare this he's
some okay no one big intentions to it to
do that it seems ok so let's regroup
here look yeah he wants to play at five
but i can i can play afro against this i
wonder i was thinking of rookie to Queen
to d2 93 yeah I can do that it's not so
easy for him to get any activity here we
go really trying to get the night on d3
at the end I take with the bishop FML 95
I but 95 I can drop to the 236 hangs so
yep I can't win back here and control g5
h6 takes Knight eggs has all my pieces
in play Queen f6 may be intending a
check on g4 no not coming okay and let
me do this I really like to exchange the
night I can take here first him
this will be tricky now don't i have d
six at the end with a fork
maybe rook takes is necessary g4 then I
don't know hmm he does not seem to
regard it as a big problem but isn't
this just a piece number taking c 70 k
by the way resigns yeah he ran right
into this this fork I'm glad to to have
been given a break here to it just win a
game yeah the problem is that blacks
position is very passive really he can
really only play a fire that he did so
without having it sir thoroughly
prepared may be here not a 6b for
something this looks I'm very
comfortable wide I have the possibility
to exchange the bishop the right moment
but the the biggest problem is we open
up the INF file where I already have
both rooks in position and I have the
night coming so we open up the position
in a very good moment for me and this is
not working at all so right flat out
losing material in fact taking taking
here first is even more precise as now
if we look at this you know it's the
same thing and the way I played it I
took here for he could have taken with
the road and yeah now I'm not so sure if
I want to do this I can but I've given
up the dark squared Bishop here yeah
it's still very good reward still very
good you sometimes need to be cautious
give up the bishop when you have the
King on a dark square and
it's fairly open with nothing going on
here okay yeah and this was just winning
winning the house um a better setup
normally for blankets if we look here he
went to see seven normally they played
like that let's say something something
along these lines trying to really
prepare everything this setup and then
f5 it's still pretty pretty nice for
white but this is playable at least okay
thanks for watching